is this the type of contract that you
would allow your daughter to sign
I'm a child I know a lot of y'all are
about to come for below please
show some mercy Shada meets with an
attorney to discuss Sabrina Bilal wants
her to sign and then she confronts Bilal
about the new condition she wants to add
to the contract there are certain things
that I want
he has to set up my business here in
Kansas City and it just belongs to me
yes she's asking about to invest in her
yoga business but she wants to fully own
it
my yoga is like my real estate let's see
how your real estate your companies yeah
the reason why my real estate is my real
estate is because I built it [ __ ]
clearly Bilal is not feeling her
proposition but what do you think do you
think Shada asking about to invest in
her yoga brand without any ownership is
fair we're gonna talk about it plus
you know he's from if we are family
right guess what y'all apparently Kobe
is part of a royal family in Cameroon
this is King joffe ruler of Zamunda I am
so confused but this news is all
according to his friend temperature do
we have a castle in Cameroon like what
is going on
you ever had a friend who over
exaggerates on your behalf yeah I think
this is one of those cases but either
way temperature came in piping hot
during his first episode and he didn't
give a damn about reading the room I'm
trying to make you understand that Kobe
has a final essay
yeah not a cool way for Emily's Family
to get introduced to Kobe's best man oh
let's get into it
[Music]
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissia have
you heard happily ever after is
returning with fan favorites on August
28th and a lot has changed but there are
some things that are still the same it
looks like Angela has a new man there's
that sexy baby
[Music]
I have no clue what happened to Michael
Jenny and submit are living as a married
couple but still having these super
dramatic fights
away from me get away from me forever
what is going on I mean who could forget
Jenny in the chair
[Music]
and Andre and Libby are back
don't be like that also Big Ed and his
fiance Liz are part of the cast and so
are Yara and Jovi but this one couple
I'm confused about
Kim and Usman how did they end up on
Happily Ever After did they even get
engaged last time I checked Usman had
Kim crying during the tell-all after it
was revealed he was trying to get back
with his ex Zara
hmm I know some of y'all are thinking
well at least we get to see more of
Kim's son hey Jamal I'm kidding I'm
seriously kidding don't be trying to
play matchmaker in the comments okay it
was just a joke but yeah I'm excited the
girl next door says quote I am so ready
for the mess and the drama Mel better
bring it to us on a plate girl you know
I am here to serve all right let's go
ahead and get into shaida and below I
just want to know if the contract is
fair when it comes to me as well after
Bilal gave Shadow the physical copy of
the prenup to review during last week's
episode this week she's talking things
over with the lawyer who reveals some
concerning news I think there are maybe
a few things that I thought were
questionable is this the type of
contract that you would allow your
daughter to sign I would
Shadow's lawyer tells her she should
alter some things in the prenup so she
asked Bilal if they could go to a cafe
so they can talk it over and for context
they have to get married in 20 days
we are definitely not seeing eye to eye
when it comes to the prenuptial
agreement once they get to the cafe
Shadow tells below that when she first
got to America she thought this was
going to be a fairy tale experience it
was like a Starbucks which I'm thinking
she means after the whole prank
situation because nothing about that was
romantic anyway Bilal tells her that
that Cinderella love that never exists
and shy really has to take a moment to
take it all in she seemed so let down by
it but it's the hard truth those fairy
tale expectations will continue to set
you up for disappointment and if you
notice most fairy tales end at the
wedding we never got to see happily ever
after with Cinderella and Prince
Charming and I bet it's because the
writers knew the actual day-to-day of a
relationship is complex and complicated
which isn't a bad thing it's actually
good it's real the Cinderella stuff
it's not real right that's infatuation
and that's not love true love is built
and it's built over time
but you got to be smart too though well
below be careful what you ask for
because shaida has been thinking about
some things and now she's clear on what
she wants Shadow tells below that her
attorney suggested she put having kids
before a certain time in the contract to
protect herself as well as full
ownership over her yoga business in
Kansas City that below told her he would
help her start she was like if Bilal is
going to assist you and get your
business started here you have to be
clear that what your own belong stays
with you
that money is my money and if something
should happen to us it's that you don't
you cannot fight me for that that's mine
so he was being very clear on that even
though we are establishing that after we
get married oh I would love to hear your
immediate reaction to that I know some
of you all are thinking but she gave up
her Yoga Studio in Trinidad for you
hold on y'all because it's about to get
rough of course we're gonna know how to
do business together we're going to have
joint stuff but when it comes to my
brand my yoga
I want to look at it as my real estate
if you know what I'm saying yeah I
understand so my yoga is like my real
estate let's see how your real estate
your companies it's yours your children
you're gonna have that for me I get it
what I was just adding on to what you
were saying though is that the reason
why my real estate is my real estate is
because I built it oh
I hurt my feelings
the hard truth Shadow tells below that
if the shoe was on the other foot she
would give him her financial assistance
and support and a heartbeat hell yeah I
will help you okay what I'm saying is if
things did not work out yeah like
meaning that if you help somebody me in
this case
and I did very successful well the
equivalent the same as saying that no
matter what I built or there's a couple
thousand dollars or a couple million
dollars or even a billion dollars worth
of real estate that all of that would be
me even though you helped me build it
it's it's all mine and you get none of
it that's what I'm just saying that's an
example of what you're literally asking
me
I was shied up I would have said
do you ever plan on cheating on me do
you ever plan on divorcing me do you
ever plan on
cheating on me absolutely not no do you
ever plan on divorcing me no okay well
this right here
doesn't matter I'm being petty but on a
serious note I wonder how all of this
prenup talk is affecting their
relationship as a whole I know as
viewers we only see a small portion of
their day-to-day but it would be
interesting to know if focusing so much
on what would happen if that
relationship ends is affecting what
they're trying to build as a couple now
if Bilal says I have to sign a prenup
there are certain things that I want
he has to set up my business here in
Kansas City and it just belongs to me
I give up so much to come here I'm
prepared to walk away if he doesn't see
it the way I do
if the lawyer comes back with a prenup
and he puts any little notes
are you going to sign it
I I
um no I'll consider it
okay Moment of Truth oh I wish I could
know immediately what you think
honestly I have mixed feelings
I do the majority of my feelings are
leaning toward if you love this woman
enough that you're about to make her
your wife and you want her to succeed
plus you have the funds why not help her
get a head start yoga is her passion I
would look at it as a favor and not
necessarily a business deal
but then there's a small part of me that
thinks well maybe she should give him 20
or 15. because he's doing something he
doesn't have to do she made the choice
to give up her business to be with him
not saying it was right or wrong but
technically he doesn't owe her this I
know that sounds harsh but if I was in
her position to be fair I would give him
some equity in the company not 50 but
like I said maybe 15. so it doesn't feel
like he's giving me a handout and once
again this is my opinion this is what I
think I would do and keyword think
because the reality of it is none of us
know what we truly would do unless we're
in that situation but please share your
thoughts I'm so eager to know how you
feel about this overall I hope Bilal
helps her whether he gets a percentage
or not but one thing I hope he never
does is throw it back in her face I'm
not saying he's that type of person but
there are some people they help you and
they are quick to say if it wasn't for
me
y'all know the rest okay
all right next week Shadow sits down
with bilal's Mom and somehow she ends up
in tears I'm looking for some advice
you don't look at your partner like a
suspect marriage is not perfect figure
out how to make it work oh god oh I
can't wait to see that all right let's
quickly touch on Emily Kobe and his
friend temperature Emily and Kobe are a
few days away from getting married and
remember she's pregnant but Kobe and her
made a pact not to tell anyone until
after the wedding including her parents
I don't even know who your groomsmen are
me neither what's yeah two other guys
Pascal and Sam are going to be coming
over from Ohio okay and then temperature
is already in town east London's Hotel
so I need to meet him and hang out with
him tonight I thought you were talking
about the weather
how do you get his name temperature I'm
just curious well um I don't know how he
came up with that but when I met him
everybody was calling him temperature
he's a nice guy I think you're gonna
like him Kobe spoke way too soon that
night he goes to have guys night with
temperature who was in Kansas for the
wedding he currently lives in Ohio but
he moved to the U.S from Africa about a
year and some change ago I feel like I
have a brother I can talk to doctor tell
me how how do I look during a venting
session Kobe ends up spilling the beans
that Emily is pregnant Kobe
huh
I don't even have money
I'm not working you know we are living
in our father's house so
it's just so much going on right now
Kobe also tells temp
we're just gonna call him temp for now
that Emily is controlling she feels like
it should always be like she's always
right Kobe that's America that's how you
understand yeah so of course the next
day when Tim meets Emily and her family
over dinner her trying to control an
African man is on the top of his mind
but even still I didn't expect him to
confront Emily about it did we still
need a few minutes
I think we're ready okay I'm gonna do
the chicken piccata
and then Kobe's gonna get lasagna you
like the Lasagna right yeah I think I
can go with that
please okay
she wants to do almost everything
she's loving it yeah
how that made him feel
yeah it would be my pleasure to see them
together
but I believe the key is just to pitch
the wife what she's supposed to do
but he's not married
while I don't agree with what
temperature just said I'm gonna give him
some Grace right now because I
understand that he is a product of his
environment he comes from a part of the
world that mostly operates in that way
and he thinks he's looking out for his
friend but what he should consider doing
is allowing Kobe to be a big boy and
make his own decisions
we the African man
we met him a whole lot of respect for my
ladies yeah so I give him respect
right do you think so
yeah of course Emily is like yes how
dare you yeah of course
you know he's from if we are family
right oh shoot no
wait look at Kobe's face was he like a
prince wait what are you saying yeah
no I'm not my dad
what your dad is my dad is from the
royal family but
yeah what the hell what
I am so confused I'm like this is huge
news like do we have a castle in
Cameroon like what is going on Kobe goes
on to explain that there are tribes in
Cameroon and the tribes have chiefdoms
which make up the royal family that his
dad is a part of I'm not sure if you
remember but Kobe opened up about his
relationship with his father my daughter
was never married to my mom like my dad
had his wife and I'm like a child out of
wedlock
yeah so I didn't really grow up with my
dad
I'm sorry to say this but he wasn't
really like my role model so yeah
temperature put him in an awkward
position there but I guess he is
technically royalty right maybe I don't
know I don't know the rules over there
either way this seems to be a clear case
of when you have a friend who over
exaggerates your life to make you look
better but you don't want to call them
out because they're trying to help you
I thought I knew Kobe pretty well you
know until this secret came out because
I'm like that's a big thing why wouldn't
you tell me I I would have told you in
the two years that we've been talking
every day forever
okay so wait
but you have no money and no Kingdom to
go rule yeah
I'm I have just me myself
he was just citing an example
I'm trying to make you understand that
Kobe has a final essay
I get married to an African not an
American man is the head of family
meaning belongs to me
well now I know why they call him
temperature he comes through and changes
the whole atmosphere in the room America
and the system is the Lydia the top so
I'm trying to like make her understand
that before going to sign that stuff
don't expect that things will be the way
it used to be
[Music]
I absolutely hate that temperature is
trying to tell me that men are the boss
in the relationships
like no we're in America honey like
that's not how it works you know yes
she's Marrying an African man but he's
marrying an American woman so they have
things they're going to have to work out
good point mom Kobe eventually speaks up
to reassure Emily's Family that he's not
going to try to control her but at the
same time he hints at how he would
ideally like things to be do you agree
with everything that temperature is
saying
um
well he said some things over right
throughout we are from Africa where you
know the man is always on top
but if there is respect in the
relationship you know communication like
you know everybody has a role to play
it's like equal
but the man is always on top
for obvious reasons this conversation
left Emily and her parents concerned and
next week's temperature who was in the
bridal party by the way stirs the pot
again we need to be a new environment
they are beating a new family so those
two kids what
I was very clear with Kobe that no one
should know about the pregnancy you told
him he's my friend why would he do that
this temperature have a cool switch is
he always going to be coming in hot
goodness all right 90 day fans fam make
sure you stick with ET because we are
covering it all I will see you next time
[Music]